The jogan Experience what's really wild
is like there's people that get away
with not telling you the numbers oh
Netflix like Netflix gets away with now
we were just discussing this last night
cuz a friend of mine was saying like
what are you thinking about this actor
strike and I said I don't really don't
know enough about it uh to comment other
than look if you're a person and you do
something like if even if you're a comic
and you do something on Netflix like
when I've done Netflix specials they
just say it's doing really well and you
go like what does that mean like how
many people are watching it it's we're
really happy yeah what does that mean
we're really happy it's doing great what
are the numbers what do you think is the
purpose of keeping it secret W it's a
genius move because they don't have to
tell you so you you can't really
negotiate B like if you do a special
that's special is 10 million people
watch it people oh [__] we got to pay
Assan more money next time because if he
finds out that this many people are
watch you don't know until you go out in
the road and then you sell more tickets
and you're like oh people enjoyed it I
guess it worked right but when you don't
have any data from the company they
could just not give you the data like on
their side it's great for negotiation
like they have to tell you [__] it's
just they have all the leverage there
was an article about this yesterday okay
uh Sandos defends not disclosing
streaming numbers creators feel felt
trapped by ratings Box Office so how
does he uh defend it I like Ted Sendo
spot by the way he's a very nice guy is
the longer paragraph is here but it's
part of our promise with creators at the
time we started creating original
programming our creators felt like they
were pretty trapped in this kind of
overnight ratings world and oh they're
they're trapped by ratings we doing this
for them yeah we're doing it for them
we're doing it for them they don't know
overnight ratings an analyst interview
that went live oh weekend box office
World defining their success and
failures Sando said during a
pre-recorded analyst interview that's a
little
gasy and as we know a show might have
enormous success down the road and it
wasn't captured in that opening box
office so part of this was the
relationship with the talent not just
the business aspect of it and I do think
that over time people are much more
interested in this uh we're on a
Continuum of today of how much data do
we publish I think we've been leading
the charge starting everyone down the
path of a top 10 publishing our top 10
list and our annual wrapup list and
everything to give a lot of transparency
to the viewing and I just expect will be
more and more transparent just say the
numbers this is weird little dance
you're doing to avoid just tell people
what the numbers are YouTube was saying
yesterday to that's on on top of this
that they might be changing the way
videos work for the I think they said
for the first 24 hours that all stats
will be live like live view viewer count
live thumbs up I guess people really
want to know that sounds opposite of
what he was just saying yeah and it what
people want they want to know what's
successful and what's not it does seem
interesting that he says that like oh we
have you know a show might do better as
time goes on and the initial box office
numbers might not reflect that but it's
like you're but then you're also
canceling all these shows the time they
get the second and third season yeah
shut up right it's like it just it just
there's no it it gives it doesn't lend
that credibility we're doing it for the
Creator guys we love you right we love
you we're doing it for you yeah yeah
that seems like very abusive
relationship so I would imagine that has
something to do with I think if you were
an actor and you were star of a Netflix
movie and it was [__] huge you would
want to know what the numbers are right
that's got to be part of their I don't
know is that part of what they're asking
for I know it's streaming Revenue I
think that was one of the things asked
you this one of the things there's like
the the the AI characters too that's a
big part of this because sag's still in
strike right I believe so yes so I think
the AI thing was there was one contract
that I don't know if it was actually
being someone actually trying to get
people to sign or was just being
discussed where they would pay the extra
like an extra would be on the set and
and then they know they own their
Digital Image they could use it forever
so they could put you in the background
of the [__] Hulk movie they could put
you in the background of so you you know
like conspiracy theorists believe they
are crisis actors that show up at every
mass shooting and start talking about
something and it's [__] like this is
the the most evil of conspiracy theories
right right but these this crisis actor
thing imagine if you just start seeing
like AI people in every [__] movie
every Disaster Movie you see that same
guy like that's that dude and that dude
probably got paid 200 bucks it's like
the willhelm scream but with like
people's faces right yeah that's what be
like oh if it's a disaster scene you
know this this guy's in it well maybe
they'll be able to morph your image give
you a mustache fake nose yeah I'm sure
they can they can tweak your face I mean
they can face swap you with different
extras do all kinds of stuff oh yeah
yeah for sure what they can do did you
see the unreal five um video game engine
the car on fire car on fire Jamie see if
you could play that someone said I I
forget the Tweet but it was something
along the lines of you're not going to
be able to ever know what's real again
no and if it feels this way looking at
the news with what's going on over you
know over in Israel and Palestine it's
like what am I seeing how much if this
is real what's yeah how like the
propaganda on top of that the like
shitty reporting [__] reporting it's
like it is like it's so interesting that
we have phones and we have the access to
information constantly and now we just
know if none of that information is true
well we just know quickly what actually
happened if you're online and and paying
attention and the the mainstream news is
so far behind that right colan Hughes
was on yesterday he was saying that you
know the original narrative was that
Israel bombed a hospital in in Gaza
right what actually happened was another
Islamic terrorist group launched a
missile it failed and it landed in the
parking lot out of the hospital so this
is fake this is the unreal five engine
you see a car on fire and then they have
a little video thing po through it just
the car is fake the rest of the video
should be real so they inserted a car
into a real scene is that what they did
no one really knows though honestly cuz
Unreal Engine looks so [__] good
there's been a renew video of the 5.3
and it looks but I could Jamie I could
imagine that's all the video engine why
would you think it could be but like
right there that person walking in the
background yeah but you could do that
you could well that would be easy
because there they're not even in Focus
that would be so easy in comparison to
this car that's in Focus it's just well
I'm just with I've watched a lot of it I
just don't I think that all they did was
add that just saying well you might be
right but either way look how good that
car on fire looks I mean it looks
[__] incredible very real and look
how the the Flames vary like the Flames
vary like an actual flamewood it's not
like sometimes you watch like digital
Flames they do the same pattern over and
over and over again again but this just
looks like real [__] fire there's a
level of Randomness it's reacting to the
thing in it yeah it's nuts man yeah the
the thing is making the smoke move
[__] dude they're so good now
you're not going to have any idea no you
can't tell you can't tell what's real at
all anymore and I think it was in
2015 they passed a law that allowed the
CIA to use propaganda on on citizens for
the greater good of the
nation know there's like that I mean
that's always been a thing though it's
funny that they didn't pass a law well
now they can't get arrested for it or no
one can get in trouble for it yeah I
guess I mean but no one was really
getting in trouble for it no one was
really getting trouble it's like it's he
killed the president allegedly right
it's it's more like them dotting their
eyes and crossing their te like let's
just make sure that no what is that that
law Jamie I was just looking it up I
just stumbled across an article from The
New York Times
1977 worldwide propaganda Network built
by the CIA I can't imagine 197 7 I don't
I mean I didn't I can't find the article
really but it's it's so hard to know
what's real and what's not real there's
yeah that's I think that's like we
talked about what the shift in coid what
it really caused it's like now I'm just
suspicious of everything of everything
everything I read I'm like what's that
what angle is it coming from who's
funding this exactly and not it didn't
used to be that way this is what comes
up about what we were just talking about
though oh M did not sign a law allowing
propaganda in the US Okay so here's the
claim former president Barack Obama
signed a law in 2012 allowing the
government to propaganda allowing
government propaganda in the US and
making it perfectly legal for the media
to purposely lie to the American people
ap's assessment false in
2013 Obama signed legislation that
changed the US information and education
exchange Act of 1948 also known as the
Smith month act the amendment made it
possible for some materials created by
the US Agency for Global media the
nation's foreign broadcasting agency to
be disseminated in the US the facts a
post circulating on Facebook with a
photo of Obama falsely states that he
repealed a ban on government propaganda
in the US when he signed the National
Defense authorization act in 2013 the
amendment did not repeal the Smith month
act but rather lifted some restrictions
on the domestic dissemination of
government funded
media okay government funded media
though is you're getting close to
propaganda right okay so here the change
essentially eased restrictions for
Americans who wanted to access
government funded
me doing it for you did Ted zandos write
this we're making we're making it easier
for you to access it the change
essentially eased restrictions for
Americans who wanted to access
government funded media content because
you know most Americans really want to
access government funded media content I
can't think of anything better would I
rather watch Game of Thrones or
government funded media content I think
I'd go allowing media produce by the US
Agency for Global media such as the
voice of America Radio free Europe Radio
Liberty to be made available to
Americans upon request it was not
possible before the law was changed even
upon request if I wanted to get through
the get it through the Freedom of
Information Act for for instance they
couldn't do it the amendment changed
that says Gabe rotman director of the
reporters committee techn committee's
technology and press Freedom project boy
when everybody puts whenever someone
puts freedom in their project like you
don't I don't trust anything that
[__] son is it Patriot Freedom you
know the Patriot Act I I just think it's
so funny that like government funded
media was behind some sort of wall to
begin with like that's that's kind of
interesting well it says it was there
was essentially deao ban on the
government dissemination of materials
originating from the state department
yeah because they we didn't trust you we
didn't trust you to just [__] make
these claims journalists are supposed to
make these claims right you're not
supposed to release the news if you're
the government no journalists are
supposed to go in there find out what's
actually going on right and then and
then you know I guess later we find out
that they're really influencing these
news companies anyway so it's like what
so funny boy oh
boy yeah I don't know it sounds like a
sneaky way to get propaganda to people
but I thought there was a there was
something else where they were was
proposing that they were allowed to use
propaganda if it was for the greater
good I thought that was a part of the
whatever was the National Defense
authorization act which the one that
allowed for indefinite detention there
was one that had like some real sweeping
oversteps where people like yo
indefinite detention is that the same
sort of stuff they used to get the guy
who made the memes this is article from
2013 but it explains everything we just
read this just this reminds me of I this
is for whatever reason reminds me of I
want to watch Fast 7even in theaters
Fast and the Furious Fast and the
Furious 7 H it was only me in the
theater well it was me it was me and
this one lady and at one point the lady
goes walks out and
leaves that's your fault you came to
fast seven yeah but it in it I think
it's fast 7 there is this hacker that
creates this thing that can see into
every phone and see into every traffic
light they can get in and the whole fast
Seven's the whole fast ner crew's job is
to get this hacker and get her program
and give it to the US military because
the US military are the good guys and
they need to have this you don't want to
end this up in the bad guys hands and
it's like I just remember thinking like
wow this is blatant like weird
propaganda in fast 7even yeah I came to
see cars jump out of you know
skyscrapers not this this interesting
well it's also they feel like those kind
of movies sell to the kind of people who
like those kind of movies like those
kind concept like if you like fast and
fury 7 you know you might have a Maga
hat you know you know you might have a
Confederate flag in your [__]
Den